If you don't know this by now,
design is one of my favorite things in the world.
Make your life as happy and bright
and cheerful as it can be.
And little details can make a huge difference.
And we don't believe that you need to break the bank
if you want to beautify a space.
So, today we're helping a viewer
with her little design dilemma,
with a few upgrades each under 30 bucks.
Take a look.
Hi Drew?
My name is Tasha.
I'm a single mom with a 13 year old daughter
living here in New York city.
And we need help with our kitchen.
Please help.
I love your designs.
You're the best.
Just please help me.
Here's my kitchen.
My cabinet doors do not shut.
This is a terrible DIY project that went really bad.
I didn't even finish.
I am so uninspired to click in here.
I have no backsplash.
My cabinets are being held together shut
with this spoon here.
I really, really need your help.
Please help.
Perfect.
Okay, please welcome Tasha.
(crowd cheering)
Hi.
Hi Tasha.
How are you today?
I'm wonderful.
How are you?
I'm really great.
I'm in my happy place.
I'm not gonna lie.
All right.
What bothers you most about your kitchen?
Oh my goodness.
First of all,
I hate the fact that I do not have a backsplash.
That's why I tried my little DIY project
with the metallic paper, which was a fail.
A horrible fail.
There's no cabinet space.
I can't prep and chop food.
Me and my daughter are bumping arms trying to prep.
And then it's just terrible.
I need help.
Okay.
Well, I am here and I am very invested
and I've worked with Sarah Monaghan,
who is my design partner in crime.
And we have really given the love to this.
All right.
First of all, we found you a backsplash
that is a peel and stick tile
and it looks great.
You can almost not tell this even has grout lines
and it's 29 99.
So get that foil down.
Oh my...
And this is what we need to do.
All right, now let's talk about your cabinets.
Sarah and I felt like new hardware was gonna be crucial.
So we found these poles and I gonna tell you,
like when I'm making things,
weight is really important for like
sheekness and expensiveness.
These are super heavy, super gorgeous,
and they're four bucks each.
So, okay.
The next thing is...
Just amazing.
Add a little light because I am a light junkie
and if you don't have the windows,
it's gonna be really hard.
Although this white is going to reflect light
and we found you these under lighting strips
that can reflect on the back splash
and create so much more light and they're 20 bucks.
All right?
Now, we're also gonna create some space
with these beautiful canisters.
They're easy to open.
I don't wanna even take the time to screw open and closed.
These are like really easy.
Just lift.
You want it to be fast
and what I always do in my kitchen,
I mean this is a much more ornate situation
than I normally have.
By the way these are fake flowers
and you can get them for 20 bucks and just keep them there,
but have a little something natural in the kitchen,
leave some fruits and vegetables out
and Tasha don't kill me,
but we're gonna Marie Kondo that kitchen.
Okay, first of all, I also got you,
this is my personal dish rack that I actually pulled
from my place, because you've just got
one of those dry mats,
which are really great,
but this has a little catch for the water
and it's white and it looks pretty.
We have got to get to crisp in your kitchen.
Splash.
And I want you to, we hang up,
'cause this is the 1950s apparently,
when we hang up,
I want you to go Marie Kondo in your kitchen
and really get rid of a lot of stuff.
I want you to get hardcore and ask yourself,
what do you need?
What do you not?
And I want you to get clean.
This Zen newness is gonna bring so much joy to your life.
And I'd seen your kitchen and you have a lot of stuff.
So I need you to get brutal on yourself.
And lastly,
when you don't have a ton of counter space
and you and your daughters are bumping elbows,
we found this really cool mechanism
that you can literally make, like basically
a chopping block on your existing stove.
So I love that these are just cutting boards
and these two are completely affordable.
So this whole thing is like under a hundred dollars.
And I know that's a lot of money,
but it's really transformative.
You have bright light,
you have cleanliness,
you have more work space.
This is a true kitchen make-over
and you can do things one at a time,
but you gotta get ruthless on your stuff, Tasha.
Oh and last detail, Sarah and I made you this.
It's a picture of you and your daughter
and it has magnets on the back.
So you can put it on the side of your fridge
because your fridge sticks out here
and you see a piece of it.
So I thought putting nice metallic frame magnet
on your fridge will create a little strip
of art rather than clutter.
Oh...
Thank you so much.
Also, you not gonna anything,
'cause we're sending all of this to you plus more Tasha,
so and a $500 gift card to hiring a handyman
to help you do all of this and get it done.
So you get in those cabinets,
you start decluttering.
You have a gentleman coming your way with 500 bucks to spend
and every single detail in this kitchen.
Tasha, thank you for participating in this with me.
Thank you so much Drew.
(murmuring)
Thank you Tasha.
(upbeat music)